guck mal da bist willkommen meine lieben
Freunde ich darf euch heute endlich mal
wieder herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einer neuen Episode
moviestarplanet falls ihr neu auf meinem
Kanal seid werdet ihr euch
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr in die Videos
erinnern die ich vor drei Jahren zu
diesem Spiel hochgeladen habe
hier gerade gesehen habt hatte ich
bereits eine Menge Spaß an diesem Spiel
und die Videos die ich davon hochgeladen
habe haben auch alle Millionen Aufrufe
gemacht also es hat auch euch richtig
richtig gut gefallen von daher dachte
ich mir stelle ich mir mal einen neuen
Charakter weil ich in meinen alten
Account irgendwie nicht mehr
reingekommen bin weil ich gehackt wurde
allerdings ist das hier jetzt mein neuer
Charakter und wir klicken einfach mal
auf okay fertig wir nennen uns Peter
Meinhardt da wird jeder denken ich will
nicht nur 70 jähriger Pädophiler Rentner
da kommen wir an meine Damen und Herren
der roten Teppich ist ausgerollt ich
habe dieses Spiel hat wirklich drei
Jahre nicht mehr gespielt ja ich kann
mich ja dazu gar nicht erinnern das hier
ist auf jeden Fall die moviestarplanet
Welt wir haben hier verschiedene
Bereiche wie beispielsweise den
haustierbereich Shopping Bereich
movietown Spiele und Chat klicken wir
als erstes mal drauf um
schenke
wenn es doch in echt so einfach wäre
Geld zu sammeln ne
ja damit sehe ich Peter meiner hat jetzt
eher weniger allerdings würde ich sagen
dass wir uns erstmal so richtig
oldschool wie in den alten Videos ins
Café bewegen um dort vielleicht neue
Freunde kennenzulernen i love Boys das
kann so
Limbo Timbo den Sekunden später
irgendjemand gerade
sehe ich genauso
auch das sehe ich eins zu eins genauso
ich bin halt no joke der einzige der oh
mein Gott Sam
IRA
ein 20 Sekunden später
sie ist weg ist wirklich kein Mensch ne
Café ist einfach leer
ey dieses Spiel hat sich echt verändert
okay wir müssen uns einen anderen Ort
suchen von daher würde ich sagen gehen
wir mal hier in den Strand da haben wir
schon baby girl 2 können wir mal kurz
hier schreiben Hallo zack
ich bin gespannt ob die
antwortet
hallo alle zusammen und Uhr plötzlich
sponnieren Baum vor mir hola guck mal
die schreibt hier wie geht's dir frage
ich jetzt einfach mal wir sind also so
langsam in dem kleinen
gesprächenchen Gespräch Gespräch
Sprachen lernen Babbel
ich habe geschrieben mir geht's auch gut
woher kommst du und sie schreibt jetzt
drei Fragezeichen ich habe sie voll
beleidigt oder so
man darf nicht fragen was ist dein
Lieblingsbaum ey diese Spieler hat sich
so verändert sonnenkrams geht dann
wieder okay versuchen wir damit ein
Gespräch aufzubauen ich esse gerne
Nudeln
ich kann das nicht so gut mit dem
Flirten die hat auch leichten
Sonnenbrand irgendwie auch in einer
Schnauze und da würde ich sagen
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt mal auf ein
anderes Mädchen
fahren Lilo 344 ist da von daher
schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal
schauen ob sie antwortet das blöde ist
dass die Josy noch so ein zwei Meter vor
uns steht am Strand aber das ist
Mallorca die Antwort ist ja scheißegal
okay sie schreibt hi schreibe ich wo
versteht ihr wegen hi wo ist denn hier
ein hi wir sind am Strand kann sein dass
da gleich eine ankommt
sie geht und sie geht hinter mich und
sie geht wieder zur Seite
Josi ist sich auch am bewegen sie geht
ich werfe jetzt mal direkt hier die
Granate in den Raum also das ergibt
keinen Sinn weil ich bin ja schon die
Granate und ich befinde mich bereits im
Raum allerdings frage ich jetzt einfach
mal ganz direkt wer mag mich am meisten
hier
um einfach mal zu schauen ohne Reise
eventuell hingehen könnte niemand
mit dir hat niemand geredet was willst
du
Stress
haha ich lache dich aus
komm doch her
Peter du Witzfigur Digger
Peter du wie gut dicker
ich habe Stress denkst ich habe Angst ey
ich habe gerade Stress mit locker
12-jährigen hier Angst ist mein zweiter
Vorname oh nein oh nein das ist nicht
gut äh ich meine dein
geil schreibt der was denkst du wer du
bist jetzt mache ich dir noch mal eine
richtige Ansage hier euch zwei
Kakerlaken verputze ich zum Frühstück
habe ich da geschrieben kann die Website
wohl nicht handeln hier meine Sachen er
schreibt nur hahaha
sag mal streiten wir uns jetzt hier um
die mädelsfische aus Fisch ab was wird
sich ab junge ich zisch ab warte ich
schreibe okay okay so ich gehe
aber dann komme ich wieder
ich gehe komplett um die Ecke dass wir
den nicht mehr sehen guck mal ich mit
meinem Mädels die alle am Start am
Strand bisschen
gutes Wetter ich freue mich kurz ich
mache kurz einen kurzen beruhigungsstand
dass ich klarkommen ich mache einen
Freudensprung
und jetzt geht's zurück
denn
wofür nehme ich denn Training für solche
Idioten wie dich da bin ich
tada fast ein Idiot
er lacht mich nur aus menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend egal komm wie scheiße
da drauf ich will ja hier keine
negativen Vibes hier versprühen und hier
Stress haben lachgrafung geht die kommen
gar nicht klar wir gehen mal rüber zu
Snoop snoobilder eins hallo die Dame
hast du Freunde hey das sind
doch
ein dritten damit am Start oder was ich
liebe euch dreien auf ey komm mal hier
rüber möchtet ihr tanzen aber der
nett ich
ich glaube die sind wirklich 12 ich habe
mies recherchiert ich gehe nach rechts
tanzen kommt gerne mit Jungs habe ich
jetzt mal geschrieben so ich schaue
jetzt gar nicht an was die da noch
schreiben hier Pippi Langstrumpf in den
komischen Söckchen auch noch anstatt
bekommen ich stelle mich jetzt einfach
mal ganz hier rechts und tanzen bisschen
nähen tanzen mal schauen ob die Jungs
kommen
eine Stunde später ich bewege mich jetzt
mal wieder zurück hier zu den Kollegen
und frag mal warum kommt ihr nicht mit
zwei Fragezeichen
irgendwie stehen die ganze Zeit nur rum
hier rechts ne bitte du bist ein Penner
Peter du bist ein Penner ich habe dieses
Spiel irgendwie echt vermisst weil es
immer man weiß gar nicht was passiert in
so einem Video und mit wem man sich über
was plötzlich unterhält und wie man
trifft aber es ist schon irgendwie echt
ein bisschen traurig
und irgendwie tanzt doch nicht mehr bei
mir ich glaube wir sind am Strand auch
falsch aufgehoben von daher würde ich an
der Stelle das heute wieder das auch
beenden meine lieben Freunde wenn euch
endlich mal wieder hier moviestarplanet
mit Luca gefallen hat dann lasst gerne
einen Daumen hoch unter diesem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen möchtet ihr mehr
moviestarplanet Videos auf meinem Kanal
wieder sehen schreibt sie gerne unten in
die Kommentare und ich
oh ich kacke jetzt